Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
peut-on aller plus vite que la lumière ?
On entend souvent dire que l'expansion de l'univers accélère certains objets plus rapidement que la lumière.
Effectivement,
certains objets voient la distance qui les sépare
augmenter plus rapidement
que la vitesse de la lumière.
Mais cela est dû à l'expansion de l'espace lui-même.
C'est-à-dire la grille sous-jacente
sur laquelle se situent les objets.
Cette grille est en constante expansion
et c'est elle qui fait augmenter
la distance entre les astres.
Cette augmentation de distance
n'est pas réellement un déplacement.
En particulier, cela ne permet pas
d'envoyer une information plus rapidement que la lumière.
Mis à part l'expansion de l'espace lui-même,
est-il donc possible qu'un objet se déplace
à l'intérieur de l'espace plus rapidement que la lumière ?
La théorie de la relativité restreinte
permet de comprendre
que la vitesse à laquelle se déplace un objet
dans l'espace modifie la façon dont s'écoule son temps.
Plus il se déplace rapidement,
plus son temps propre ralentit
et s'écoule lentement par rapport à l'environnement.
S'il transporte une horloge,
les aiguilles de cette horloge
prennent alors plus de temps pour faire un tour complet
que celles d'une horloge immobile dans son entourage.
Ainsi, plus un objet se déplace rapidement dans l'espace, plus il se déplace lentement dans le temps.
Pour quantifier la situation,
on peut essayer de tracer un graphique très simple,
qui représente l'écoulement du temps
par rapport à la vitesse de l'objet.
Pour un objet immobile, de vitesse zéro,
le temps s'écoule à 100 % de son rythme normal.
D'autre-part, pour un objet
qui se déplacerait à 100% de la vitesse de la lumière,
le temps ne s'écoulerait tout simplement plus. L'écoulement du temps est alors de zéro.
On peut naturellement penser que si le temps ralentit jusqu’à s’arrêter lorsqu'on atteint la vitesse de la lumière,
il serait peut-être possible de remonter dans le temps
si l'on pouvait se déplacer encore plus vite.
Plus on irait au delà de la vitesse de la lumière,
plus on remonterait rapidement dans le passé,
avec un écoulement du temps qui serait négatif.
C'est un idée qui semble à première vue plausible
et même très attractive.
Cependant, elle se base sur une hypothèse très forte que l'on a postulée sans le préciser.
C'est le fait d'avoir relié et prolongé les deux points
par une ligne droite.
Il existe bel et bien une certaine courbe
qui relie ces deux points
et sur laquelle se situe tout objet de l'univers.
N'importe quelle forme de matière,
n'importe quel objet se trouve sur cette courbe
et dès lors qu'il se déplace à une certaine vitesse,
son temps propre s'écoule forcément
à un rythme qui est bien déterminé.
En quelque sorte, le temps ralentit de la même façon pour tout les corps dès lors qu'il ont la même vitesse.
Mais lorsqu’on réalise l'expérience pour déterminer
si cette courbe est bien une ligne droite,
on mesure qu'un corps
qui se déplace à 50 % de la vitesse de la lumière,
voit son temps s'écouler non pas à 50 %,
mais environ 87 % de son rythme normal.
De même, un corps qui se déplace
à 80 % de la vitesse de la lumière,
voit son temps propre s'écouler à 60 %.
Et un corps se déplaçant
à 25 % de la vitesse de la lumière,
ne perçoit presque pas de différence
avec une immobilité,
car son temps s'écoule toujours
à près de 97 % du rythme normal.
La courbe qui se dessine alors sous nos yeux
n'est pas une ligne droite,
mais plutôt un quart de cercle.
Toute la matière contenue dans l'univers
se situe quelque part sur ce quart de cercle.
Comme notre ligne droite précédemment,
cette courbe peut être prolongée en un cercle complet.
A gauche du graphique, les vitesses négatives
correspondent tout simplement à des vitesses
quand on se déplace dans le sens opposé.
Si se déplacer vers la droite donne une vitesse positive,
par exemple un kilomètre par heure,
alors se déplacer avec une vitesse négative
de moins un kilomètre par heure ( -1 km/h )
revient seulement
à se déplacer avec cette vitesse vers la gauche.
Pour commencer, on remarque qu'il n'est jamais possible ni de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière,
ni de dépasser une vitesse temporelle de 100 %.
En effet, même pour un objet hypothétique
qui remonterait dans le temps,
c'est-à-dire avec un écoulement temporel négatif,
il serait strictement impossible
de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière
car tout objet est confiné sur ce cercle.
La question intéressante n'est donc plus de savoir
s'il est possible de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière,
mais plutôt d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi une telle chose est impossible,
pourquoi la courbe prend une forme de cercle
et ce qu'il y a de si particulier
avec la vitesse de la lumière.
Commençons par nous pencher
sur la forme bien particulière de cette courbe, un cercle.
La particularité d'un cercle
est que tous les points qui le composent
se trouvent à la même distance du centre.
Pour un objet quelconque,
la quantité qui a réellement du sens
n'est ni sa vitesse dans l'espace,
ni le rythme d’écoulement de son temps,
mais plutôt sa distance depuis le centre du graphique.
Cette quantité prend en compte
à la fois le déplacement de l'objet dans l'espace
et son déplacement dans le temps.
Il s'agit en fait là d'une unification des deux vitesses,
on mélange à la fois la vitesse de l'objet
dans l'espace et dans le temps,
c'est sa vitesse dans l'espace-temps.
Quelque soit le vitesse d'un objet,
même s'il accélère ou ralentit,
sa position dans le graphique va changer,
mais sa distance au centre va toujours rester la même.
Cette quantité
est une constante fondamentale, universelle,
qui régit absolument tous les corps de l'univers.
C'est cette quantité
qu'on appelle la vitesse de la lumière.
Il est important de comprendre
que la vitesse de la lumière est quelque chose de fondamental.
Elle n'est pas importante
parce que la lumière se déplace avec cette vitesse.
Elle est importante parce que dans l'espace-temps, quand on prend en compte l'espace et le temps,
c'est la vitesse
à laquelle se déplacent absolument tous les objets.
Avec cette idée en tête,
on comprend mieux le phénomène qui est à l'oeuvre.
Les objet ne peuvent pas dépasser
la vitesse de la lumière
tout simplement parce qu'ils se déplacent toujours
avec exactement cette vitesse.
La seule marge de liberté que peut avoir un corps
est lorsqu'il distribue cette vitesse
entre l'espace et le temps.
Si l'objet est plutôt en haut du graphique,
il donne beaucoup de vitesse au temps
et peu de vitesse à l'espace.
Son temps s'écoule presque normalement,
mais il ne se déplace pas très vite dans l'espace.
Cela correspond
au comportement des objets de notre quotidien
qui sont immobiles par rapport à nous,
ou du moins relativement lents
quand on les compare à la vitesse de la lumière
D'autre part,
si un objet se situe plutôt en bas à droite du graphique,
il donne davantage de vitesse à l'espace qu'au temps.
Les objets les plus rapides de l'univers
se déplacent très vite dans l'espace,
mais par conséquent, très lentement dans le temps.
Ils évoluent au ralenti par rapport à nous.
Cela correspond en particulier à la lumière,
qui est le cas extrême
où toute la vitesse est donnée uniquement à l'espace.
Une particule de lumière se déplace extrêmement vite,
mais son temps ne s'écoule alors plus du tout.
Si elle portait une horloge imaginaire,
ses aiguilles resteraient immobiles.
Un objet qui accélère n'augmente pas sa vitesse.
Il va seulement la convertir d'une vitesse temporelle,
qui le fait progresser dans le temps,
en une vitesse spatiale qui le fait avancer dans l'espace.
Et vice-versa.
Un objet qui va ralentir convertit une partie de sa vitesse spatiale en vitesse temporelle.
Globalement, sa vitesse dans l'espace-temps
est restée constante,
il se déplace toujours à la vitesse de la lumière.
C'est seulement la répartition de cette vitesse,
entre temps et espace, qui a été modifiée.
Pour finir, cette représentation
sous la forme d'un graphique a beaucoup d'avantages
car elle très visuelle et permet de donner
une intuition très forte de certains phénomènes.
Par exemple, on peut se demander s'il existe des objets qui se situent sur la partie basse du graphique.
Intuitivement,
de tels objets devraient remonter dans le temps,
car leur vitesse temporelle serait négative.
Et effectivement, on peut,
dans un certain cadre,
interpréter qu'il existe bel et bien
un type de particule dans l'univers
qui se situe dans cette partie du diagramme.
C'est ce qu'on appelle communément l'antimatière.
Les particules d'antimatière
ont les mêmes propriétés que les particules normales,
si ce n'est que leur charge électrique est opposée.
Elles sont en quelque sorte les symétriques
des particules ordinaires.
La partie haute du graphique
est la partie où se trouve la matière ordinaire,
tandis que la partie basse, son symétrique,
est le monde de l'antimatière.
Les particules de lumière, quant à elles, les photons,
sont leurs propres symétriques,
car elles se trouvent à l'extrême droite du diagramme.
Le photon est donc sa propre antiparticule.
Enfin,  il faut quand même prendre
quelques précautions car toute cette représentation
n'est basée que sur le modèle de la relativité restreinte.
Modèle qui n'est exact
que dans le cas d'un univers vide, parfaitement plat.
Dans la réalité, notre univers n'est pas plat.
Il est parsemé d'étoiles et de planètes qui déforment
en quatre dimensions la géométrie de l'espace-temps,
et il faut alors utiliser la relativité générale.
En relativité générale, la gravité n'existe pas.
C'est seulement la courbure de l'espace-temps
qui va naturellement convertir
la vitesse temporelle des objets en vitesse spatiale.
Si une pomme tombe d'un arbre,
alors qu'elle était au départ immobile,
c'est parce que son écoulement dans le temps
a été progressivement converti en vitesse vers le bas.
Et ce, par la courbure spatio-temporelle
engendrée par la masse de la Terre.
Si on observe de loin un objet qui se trouve à coté
d'un corps massif comme la Terre,
le graphique qui lui est associé va alors se déformer.
A proximité d'un trou noir notamment,
le cercle se déforme tellement
qu'il se réduit de plus en plus
au fur et à mesure que l'objet se rapproche de l'horizon.
Lorsqu'il finit par atteindre l'horizon des événements,
le cercle est alors entièrement contracté,
ce qui signifie
que l'objet n'a alors plus aucune marge d'évolution.
De notre point de vue, il reste figé,
immobile à la surface du trou noir.
Lorsqu'on les observe depuis un endroit éloigné,
tous les objets qui tombent dans un trou noir
finissent par se figer à sa surface.
Pour un tel objet, ce phénomène n'est qu'une illusion.
Pour lui, il est tout à fait possible
de traverser l'horizon du trou noir,
et il continue progressivement sa chute
vers la singularité centrale
Mais pour nous, en tant qu'observateurs
qui regardons la situation depuis l’extérieur,
toutes les informations qui décrivent cet objet,
ralentissent progressivement jusqu'à s’arrêter
pour rester finalement figées à la surface du trou noir.
L'une des conséquences les plus importantes
de ce phénomène
est que l’entropie d'un trou noir, c'est-à-dire
en quelque sorte son information et sa température,
est entièrement décrite et distribuée à sa surface.